merci mon cher jean merci à tous les
amis de cette fédération du rhône qui
nous accueille aujourd'hui et merci bien
sûr au président de la région auvergne
rhône jan
nous sommes heureux mon cher laurent
d'être à tes côtés
ici chez toi et d'être derrière toi pour
donner un cap à notre famille politique
et pour regarder l'horizon pour
redresser notre pays
merci pour ce que tu apportes de
renouveau de conviction de force de
courage dans un moment difficile
nous abordons mes chers amis le choix le
choix de nos candidats pour les
élections européennes du 26 mai prochain
cette élection sera la première après ce
funeste printemps 2010 est où nous avons
vu pour la première fois nous avons vu
et subi pour la première fois cette
double défaite
certains nous croyez morts certains nous
disent est mort certains espérés notre
disparition
nos adversaires traditionnels s'y sont
employés
c'est le rôle et finalement on ne peut
on ne peut que s'y opposer mais avec la
force de nos convictions
d'autres de façon plus surprenante ont
essayé en l'intérieur même de nos rangs
de s'additionner à ce cortège qui
voulaient voir disparaître cette forme i
cette famille politique qui incarne la
droite républicaine cette famille
politique qui depuis le général de
gaulle georges pompidou valéry giscard
d'estaing jacques chirac nicolas sarkozy
a donné la force a donné cette force à
la vème république et a construit cette
france forte généreuse et courageuses
que nous avons toujours défendu alors
aujourd'hui
bien sûr nous devons aborder cette
échéance avec cette volonté de renouveau
et de redressement en qualité de
président de la commission nationale
d'investiture
j'ai l'honneur de vous demander
d'approuver le choix que nous avons
faits sur la proposition de la direction
du mouvement avec ses premiers candidats
que nous avons l'honneur de vous
présenter aujourd'hui et cani dans
quelques instants va vous présenter
nous avons fait ses choix en fonction de
quelques critères simples d'abord en
nous adaptant à ce piège qu'a voulu nous
tendre emmanuel macron celui du
changement des règles nous sommes pour
la première fois depuis trois élections
européennes soumis un scrutin national
ce scrutin national impose aussi des
choix nationaux et des règles nationales
et puis nous avons défini lors de la
première commission d'année nationale
d'investitures principes simples celui
de marié l'expérience et le
renouvellement nous avons décidé que 50%
de nos candidats seraient renouvelées
c'est le signe qu'à souhaiter la
commission d'investiture mais bien au
delà l'ensemble de notre direction
derrière laurent de regarder et de bâtir
ce renouveau de la droite républicaine
mais nous avons fait aussi nous avons
fait aussi confiance à l'expérience
l'expérience de nos députés sortants au
parlement européen pour que la voix de
la france que la voix des républicains
et notamment que la voix des
républicains au sein du ppe cherche rêve
dole soit toujours aussi forte et aussi
entendu donc nous avons fait le choix et
a dit tout à l'heure vous le dira de
renouveler notre confiance à des députés
européens sortants qui ont effectué un
travail de très grande qualité au
parlement européen et puis
je veux saluer à mon tour aussi celles
et ceux qui ont fait le choix est bien
de ne plus briguer insuffle un mandat
parlementaire et je pense notamment à
michèle alliot marie avec ce souvenir
bien entendu de cette formidable
président du rpr il a donné et a servi
notre pays avec tant de force
nous avons fait aussi le choix mon cher
jean du rassemblement du rassemblement
et je salue à mon tour
cette union qui s'inscrit dans ce que
nous sommes depuis la création de l'ump
des républicains d'alliance avec nos
amis centristes et la présence
aujourd'hui d'hervé morin et des
candidats qui seront sur cette liste et
voit mieux que les républicains sont
aujourd'hui aussi et toujours cette
force qui peut porter et incarner le
rassemblement
mes amis oui nous avons une liste de
convictions une liste conviction avec un
leader qui depuis son engagement depuis
que laurent wauquiez a souhaité qu'ils
portent cette force ce message ses
convictions a donné une impulsion très
forte à notre famille politique et un
autre liste je veux saluer
françois-xavier bellamy je veux le
saluer
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'ils représentent il représente
dans la foi cette droite de conviction
de valeur cette droite qui ne s'excuse
pas d'être de droite
cette droite qui est fier cette droite
qui assume et qui porte un héritage qui
dit que nous ne venons pas de nulle part
parce que neuf savoir d'où nous venons
c'est la meilleure garantie pour savoir
où nous voulons aller et aussi où nous
ne voulons pas aller françois b la vie
un quart de cette france cette france
héritière d'une civilisation
cette europe qui porte aussi une
civilisation avec françois-xavier bel
habit maredret les caricatures les
attaques à auxquelles il a répondu avec
beaucoup de sérénité beaucoup de force
avec beaucoup d'énergie et bien cette
candidature
elle porte aujourd'hui à nesle le
renouveau d'une famille politique parce
qu'elle repose sur un héritage
elle repose sur des valeurs et elle est
entourée d'hommes et de femmes de
conviction
alors oui cette liste c'est celle des
convictions
après l'udc celle du rassemblement c'est
une liste sommes des deux femmes de
compétences et vous allez le mesurer
dans quelques instants
mes chers amis notre responsabilité est
grande elle est immense
elle est grande pour notre famille
politique mais elle est surtout grande
pour la france nous avons et nous
l'avons encore mesuré jeudi soir nous
avons vu la triste alternative entre
cette illusion macro nist fait de
technocratie fait de communication
artificielle est stérile et
l'aventurisme des extrêmes entre eux
cette alternative à laquelle certains
voudraient se résoudre et à laquelle
certains voudraient nous contraindre eh
bien nous avons un chemin c'est le
chemin de la responsabilité
c'est le chemin de la reconquête nous
allons le bâtir avec laurent wauquiez
grâce à laurent wauquiez
rick après brique pour la france et pour
l'europe une europe que nous voulons
sans effacer ce que nous sommes sans
effacer notre héritage sans effacer nos
convictions
une europe qui nous protège et une
europe qui donne à la france la place
essentielle celle d'une assise d'une
nation qui veut regarder l'avenir avec
optimisme avec confiance et avec
détermination
alors
merci riz